يبدو ان الحريه والتغيير تسعى لان تنهي
الشوط الاول من مباحثتها مع المكون
العسكري الى اتفاق ايطالي يتم التوقيع
عليه خلال الايام المقبله بينما يعمل
الاخير على اكمال الشوط دون نتائج هذا ما
تكشفه معلومات العربيه بعد جوله من
اللقاءات الثنائيه تتزايد التسريبات من
جهه وكذلك الامال والتوقعات من جهه اخرى
الاسبوع الى عشره ايام يتم
الاتفاق على كيفيه توقيعه همم والموقعين
عليه ومن ثم الحوالي همم همم اربعه الى ست
اسابيع نصل الى همم الاتفاق النهائي
على الضفه الاخرى هناك تحالفات سياسيه
توسع يوما بعد اخر لتقطع الطريق امام
توقيعي اي اتفاق جديد بعض
المكونات السياسيه مركزين على همم على
حوار ثنائي لنخرج من هذا الحوار الثنائي
فلابد بانخرج بتواصل مع كل القوه السياسيه
الحد الادنى من استقطاب القوه السياسيه من
خارج مركزيه الحريه والتغيير لم يتم فحركه
الكفاح المسلح الحزب والاتحادي
والديمقراطيه الاصل نظارات البيجامه
والعموديات المستقله بل هو الاحزاب التي
شاركت في الثوره ما زالوا يرفضون التسويه
25 اكتوبر بنفس الغور التي وقعت على
الوثيقه الاولى في تقدير امر صعب لابد من
تنازلات ولابد من تضمين همم
عديد من القوه الموجوده الان في الساعه
وليها صوت ولها تاثير
فهي تواصل الحرك وترفض التسويه
اي غير دي حاجات بتخصك بيانات ثانيه
الكيانات دي في النهايه التنزيل بهاوي حتى
تنزيل بها في السودان اذا في السودان في
فاعلين كثيرين
غير ان البعض يعول على ان تبذل الاليه
الثلاثيه وكذلك اللجنه الرباعيه جهود
مضاعفه بان يكون الاتفاق قاب قوسين او
ادنى لينا يعقوب العربيه الخرطوم